if i think big
i'm gonna have to spend more
that's a common
thought that a lot of entrepreneurs have
and one that came in to me from one of
my youtube viewers rosie
roses open up a shop in north london two
months away and
wants to grow this thing wants to have a
lot of success with her business and is
wondering should i start small or should
i think big
but thinking big is going to cost me a
lot more money
here's the thing this is this is so
important to understand
you want to think big
but you need to act small
you think big because that's what
keeps you going that's what keeps it
going through all the crap when things
get really hard with your business you
have a big vision of of what you want
the world to look like and how you want
people to use your products and services
and the impact and the money you're
gonna have
that's that's what drives you but you
start small
here's why it's so important okay if you
think big and you act big from the start
and you go out and you take out
a loan
right and you really use this money to
buy a huge store not just this little
store but you get a bigger store or
multiple stores and then you need to
market it and you take out
advertisements on the radio and tv and
and leafleting and everything you do to
create this business and you hire staff
you take out this huge loan to make this
happen the chances
of you making it are tiny
it's possible
but it's tiny
the reason is when you first start a
business you're gonna make a ton
of incorrect assumptions okay you're
going to write in your business plan
that you think you know you're going to
do this and then this is going to happen
it almost never works out that way if
you look at most successful companies
the idea that they started with at the
very beginning of what they thought the
company would look like is never how it
actually turns out
so the danger in going big too quickly
is that you spend all this money and
time
going in a direction
that is going to fail
because you're not only making one
mistake at a time you're making hundreds
of mistakes at a time and so the chances
of that working out is minuscule
where it's better
to start on a small scale
start making your mistakes one at a time
start by testing your different
marketing levers and seeing what works
and when you figured out something that
is working for you if it's radio ads if
it's leafleting if it's partnerships
whatever it is that is starting to drive
sales for you then you invest into
making that bigger and then bigger and
bigger and bigger
i encourage entrepreneurs to think big
because a lot of us have a limited
belief that we're only so good we can
only have so much of an impact we don't
see ourselves as being great
and i see a lot of greatness within a
ton of entrepreneurs and it frustrates
me that they don't see it within
themselves they don't have the
confidence to really build up
their business is something that can
really help a lot of people
so when i say think big
that's what i'm talking about it
frustrates me to always work with
entrepreneurs who don't believe in
themselves
but when it comes to actually executing
your plan
you start small you have you're thinking
big but you're starting small step by
step
testing your assumptions making your
mistakes with this
little negative outcome that can come
from it
you prove to yourself that this can work
and then expand from there and the sky
literally is the limit and if you do it
that way
you think big but you start small
your chances of success go up
dramatically and that's what i want for
you because i don't want to see you take
on a huge loan because evan said think
big and end up failing and have this
crushing debt over you for the rest of
your life and be afraid to get back in
the business because your first one
didn't work out and was so painful
it's possible it's possible to have a
huge
massively successful company
and it starts with combining thinking
big
with starting small
belief
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up below and i want to hear you
have to think leave a comment underneath
let me know what's on your mind let me
know what questions you have for your
company i'll make a video response thank
you so much and i'll see you soon